Dancing with the Stars juniors kicked
off with lots of high-energy
performances and ended with a tearful
double elimination
I tried woke up with the heaviest heart
building it hurts several of our
favorite kids Stars sparkled and shined
as they sashayed across the ballroom
floor including honey boo boo who
brought the fire with her salsa routine
[Applause]
[Music]
tied at the top of the leaderboard both
with 24 out of 30 actress Arianna
Greenblatt's
and Stevie Wonder's son mandala Morris
[Music]
despite so many standouts two dancing
pairs were sent home from team kiev
addison and laughs and from team Jenna
Tripp and Haley visibly disappointed but
drew dancing stars in our eyes
et spoke with Addison and Lev about
their experience on the show it's like
it's like we're all one big family a lot
of fun dances and a lot of a lot of
laughs I would say it rips mom Bristol
Palin told us she's simply proud of her
son and everything he's learned
I said trip have fun make friends you
know learn some manners with girls you
know how are you gonna you're gonna
learn how to dance just have fun make
friends and that's what he did he had
such an amazing time and their memories
that he's gonna have forever
[Music]